how is it going bro my name is anyone
out there
hello my name is I think there's someone
here sucking me what about that Sledge
whoa hey hey hey you I saw you through
the
steam Su fire axe I don't know if I can
walk through here oh ow steam you scar
me don't scare me steam that's right all
right welcome back to condomed um oh
here it is hey don't call coming now I'm
going to do my signature move document
is a standard City issue train schedule
all right pressure has been applied from
a stylus highlighting two routes both
originating from Central Metro I have no
idea what you're talking about right now
TOS departing 510 730 930 a.m. Route 66
leads to Bri all right I we go there
then to thewest O that sounds creepy
9:30 a.m. and midnight oh even creepier
H so he goes to both locations regularly
two murb I've also determined DNA from
the sweat sample in the train matches
DNA from the cigarette what's going on
over
here give me that I'll save you I'll
call
you I don't think that's a word at least
I think so cool something's still not
adding up yeah I don't know what's up
with that guy but anyway here is
building that's right who wants to
battle hey what are you doing there what
the hell is he whoa don't two of you hey
you know who my favorite Pokemon is
Pikachu hey where are you going she's
like nope you got a Pikachu over here
Pika Pig Pika Pig hey [__] come
on what are you I love how they
run Mars I got whoa who seriously ow
what are you
doing [__] oh she had her period hey
hey don't mess with peep
that's what you get from messing with
people or his cousin I do they live
under here move
OB
oh look at you you're a fine Beauty look
at you I just want to stick it somewhere
inappropriate all right
boot and health pack maybe we're going
down here I don't know about that ah
dude I don't want to go where they live
it's nasty and whoa big jump down cool
man whoa oh it's just a valve first
steam scares me then valve
that's all right whoa whoa whoa I hear
someone all right [__] stop scaring
me all right I don't even know if I'm
doing oh I got to turn off the steam
from before I guess you turn it off this
way let's check it out don't you dare
scare
me
hey I'm so sick of you and you're sh
Running Man sick of it you better come
here hey I got a
shotgun the hell is he doing whoa what
what are you
doing the [__] was
that freaking Jesus came out of nowhere
I taste him bro that's what I did all
right so the steam should be gone now
cool it is question is if we need sledy
or not I don't think we need
him it's you and me shotty
shatty let me tell you one
time sh like a melody in my head that I
can't keep out got me thinking like shot
shot people with my shotgun that was a
really lame all right the suspect's
trail has ah [__] hate when it goes cold
just like my turkey sandwich search
lower Tunnels for any information that
he might have left behind all right I'll
do that it's
locked to platform level not yet sir not
yet
hey hey what a I was supposed to hey
don't be sneaky with me don't I don't
play games man whoa ow [__] you that's
what you get I
don't why would anyone oh okay I thought
you would grab the entire thing um am I
running in circles again ah cool I am
well oh barrels oh we got a trail spy
tool spy time it's a dead bird lame
barrels you probably tricked me to come
here you little
shits uh
whoa who started the ending right when I
came what the hell is that anyway
I don't know man I don't know about
this hey hey hey hey one at a time
ladies
boom hey hey hey T that's right boot
boot triple boot quad
boot [__] everything boot hey hey
don't don't
a they are [__] powerful before they
died from one taste now they have more
Health it makes no [__] sense that is
Buller that's right I said
it God damn it I'll see you in a couple
all right we are back
[__] now I don't know how to do
this [__]
you [__] there's so many right now I
need his
weapon all right bring it [__] oh you
hit your lady blockage okay double hit
it blockage oh nice you kill your buddy
oh you want the kiss oh I kiss you P
while you're ladies what the hell's up
so many of you God damn everyone take a
shell pill right now I don't even know
what the [__] they came from out of
everywhere
space thank you I needed that this game
is getting difficult Su steamy oh you're
steaming hot lady that's right okay
let's go up here I guess it's difficult
game man sometimes you got to use the
com and [__] headb people hey hey hey
hey I know you're bad as and [__] but I
don't like that I'm out of
here God damn the taser doesn't really
work anymore don't taste me bro oh I
taste you
bro
boom
blockage blockage oh Deni denied you see
that oh you're covered in blood blockage
oh double blockage triple and but in the
balls ow oh nice nice you can block too
I see die already holy [__] hey hey you
want to
catch I'm just kidding
buter I like how he
died hey man how you okay is he
dead sad when they die barel I don't
care if you die
though so maybe in here oh there's
health
no need to go up here I think but there
was two of them wasn't it where the
other one go I don't like
this all right we got Health at
least I should probably Quicks save or
something and a dead bird I should call
you
Rael Rael Rael come here God damn
Rael hey I needed a shovel I
think I don't see why I collect dead
birds don't don't worry about it I mean
it's a it's a personal thing you could
never
understand all right what do we have
here hey thank
you
oh you you back in the closet take me in
the closet no [__]
you man shav why don't you protect me I
call you Ron that's what the [__] it's
your problem man that's my bird my bird
it's Ron is my side that Ginger [__]
it's my little sweet sugar tit seriously
everyone is crazy climbing [__] no what
am I I don't
even why I don't
cck stop doing I
don't what happen no I stopped recording
I didn't even notice okay there we go
every something happened with my game I
don't get it that probably look
extremely weird from
yours oh my
God I
don't oh my God oh
my oh my oh my sweet Jesus Sweet Baby
Jesus in a baby crab I don't what's
going on on here what is this I don't I
don't like this place not anymore before
I thought you were guys were pretty cool
now I realize you're all just a bunch of
psychopath you just want my shovel I
will never let you have my shovel
[__] no one touches my
shovel oh that's right no one don't you
don't worry shovel okay pretty I love
you I know you love me everyone loves me
but if you cheat on me again shovel I
might consider killing you you can never
kill me I'm a shovel I know I know you
don't have a soul but we're working on
that baby we're working on
that what the hell man are you you
little oh oh I'm I I can't even
commentate anymore I'm
just
what what what am I'm so confused I
what's up and down is that down whoa
grab shovel I already have oh that's
right I cheat on you now
shovel silly girl
okay I think we need to go back and
around or something and backing up
backing up backing up back you enough
cuz my shovel taught me good that's
right I shovel the head oh there we go
abandoned tunnels keep out
shovel power whoa whoa I didn't mean to
do that shovel what did you do look what
you did sorry P it's okay okay it's calm
down every increase steam pressure to
rupture okay another one of you I hear
one [__] me I don't like
this man hey what are you doing
following me shovel is mine it's mine
[__] you down on your knees that's
right okay steam
out there hope this is the only one I
don't want to do it more than
once are we good ah course it's th don't
you dare come
alive why am I doing
this hey hey hey hey I see you down
there no no no not so many one at a time
taste the
power that's right ah [__] I'm scared
please please don't come
here come on man hey man all right
Pikachu and boot in the balls boot in
the balls boot in the balls how many
balls do you have man oh oh oh you want
a
kiss I love he grabs him I didn't notice
before all right lady it's your
turn you're so stupid so stupid no one
likes your
style so you guess for scaring me before
there got to be another valve
here maybe in
here am I walking in circles Now where's
the other valow man
where uh that one was pretty clear oh
there it is why didn't I see it all
right here we
go who battle what did you do now you
will die P I will never die ever oh cool
health pack
shovel power whoa what's going
on what's going on
here oh back to the railways I guess
it's back here shely can't go there shy
we got to cross our ways over here this
is creepy as [__] I don't like this shov
hold me tight I'm holding it baby good
whoa whoa whoa
okay where's the dead birds is there any
dead birds
around okay this these are some really
whoa whoa let's go in here in the next
episode oh maybe I can finish uh no it's
actually a saving Point here so I might
as well end it anyway like your fav if
you enjoyed subscribe to com Ro today
and I'll see you next episode stay
awesome
[Music]
Bros look at you [__] ow ow man is
there any way to finish this like
without there we go no ah I guess it
doesn't matter
hey looky you want a foot